hallo leute herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem neuen video von eurem
essen youtuber lieblingsband menschen
mit dabei sind noch da
jede vierzigste straftat in deutschland
betrifft cannabis
was sagen hier arbeitet ein gesicherter
will bei der deutschen versicherung war
sich ja die allianz wir sind jetzt im
hause angekommen und gehen jetzt auf
dieses ding das dreht sich im kreis
die trotz des momentan dritter faktor
ein paar sekunden später
das ist ein monitor hier und der film
ist andere wie sie springt und
projiziert andere auf das spiel 5670 das
ist der leichteste kurs ist der
mittelschwere kursen den schwierigsten
kurs macht sandra jetzt die weg
[Gelächter]
rtr
bisher hangeln und jetzt ist
um salat
wird
da ist der stopp knopf sandra da musst
du drauf drücken anders auf den letzten
metern ihrer jump haus mit wahnsinn was
die zeit zwei minuten 4
ein kleines suchbild der der sandra
findet krieg zehn millionen euro teilte
richtig habe ich uns einen spaß erlaubt
und sandra in so einem schaumstoff hand
geschubst
das problem war dann nur die kann da
nicht mehr raus
[Musik]
die nächste völkerball spielen und hier
sind die regeln hier steht auch keine
beleidigung
das ist unit auch spaß am sport deswegen
sitzt sie am rande werfen dachte ich das
ist menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend haus das von video lassen
ich hoffe dass das video hier heute
jetzt nur so kurz gegen die sache ist
ich habe einfach mal die kamera
mitgenommen und wenig deschamps gefallen
sind und habe mir gedacht da wird
bestimmt ordentliche scheiße wieder
rauskommen
da hat sich an dem tag auf jeden fall
ordentlich weh getan aber zum glück ist
naja deutsche versicherung versichert
wenn euch das login gefallen hat dann
das gerne einen daumen hoch hier unter
dem video hier da abonniert main kanals
noch kein jahr der luke schulzeit und
jetzt würde ich einfach nur noch sagen
[Musik]